if you happen to be walking out in the
arid open plains of southwest queensland
australia you might see the black head
of a snake appearing out of a crack in
the dry ground basking in the intense
heat of the australian sun
while it might not look as immediately
threatening as a cobra or a rattlesnake
this is an animal you want to avoid at
all costs
it's the inland taipan the most venomous
snake in the world
according to its lethality rating the
ld50 its venom is about seven times more
deadly than that of the hook nosed sea
snake
around 23 times more potent than the
indian cobra and 72 times more deadly
than the venom of the king cobra
one bite from the king cobra releases on
average 420 milligrams of venom enough
to kill around 2 600 mice
but one bite from the inland taipan
which only releases about 44 milligrams
of venom on average could kill up to 220
000 mice and in some cases inland
taipans have been shown to inject over
110 milligrams of venom in a single bite
that's enough to kill half a million
mice or over 100 humans
even a small bite from an inland taipan
can cause permanent damage and if you're
not given the taipan antivenom within 45
minutes you'll most likely bleed out
from your wound your kidneys will shut
down and your body will go into
paralysis leading to respiratory failure
and death
before anti-venom was readily available
every bite from an inland taipan was
fatal
but why is it so lethal and how does it
do so much damage to the human body and
how did it evolve to become the most
dangerous venom in the world
to understand why the inland taipan is
so deadly we first need to understand
where venom emerged in the evolutionary
tree
like so many hunting and feeding traits
in animals venom in snakes appeared due
to dramatic changes in geography and
habitat over millions of years
it's not clear exactly when and how
venom appeared in snakes it could have
either come from a single origin around
170 million years ago leading to
toxicity in the venom of many diverse
reptile species or it could have evolved
independently across multiple lineages
so we might not know exactly when it
evolved but it's generally understood
why it evolved
based on fossil records it's been
suggested that the first snakes caught
and killed their prey by mechanical
constriction
like modern constrictors these early
snakes had robust vertebrae and short
but powerful muscles between the
vertebrae allowing the spine to flex at
multiple positions
a snake constricts its prey by capturing
it within several loops in the spine and
then applying pressure using the short
distances between the vertebrae to
create tight angles within the loops
the prey's blood flow to vital organs
the brain in the heart is restricted
causing the animal to fall unconscious
and eventually die from cardiac arrest
the forest-rich habitats of the jurassic
era were perfectly suited to this exact
sort of predation
a snake could hide in the dense
undergrowth patiently waiting for its
prey to pass grabbing it quickly and
trapping it between the loops of its
spine before it could escape
the relationship between a snake's
method of killing their prey and their
habitat is something we still observe
today
we tend to find constricting snakes like
boas in jungles and dense environments
as these habitats are perfect for
ambushing their prey but what happens if
you open up the environment
during the miocene period from about 23
to 6 million years ago
environments across the world began to
slowly change
the air became cooler the conditions
drier
and differences in local climates became
more pronounced
leading to areas opening up to form
savannas
these were perfect for the development
of rodent and bird life but less ideal
for the constricting snakes the snakes
that were ideally suited for
constriction weren't suited to chasing
animals across these new more open
landscapes
this required longer multi-segmented
muscle change instead of shorter more
powerful blocks of muscles used for
constriction
and so if snakes needed to chase their
prey they also needed a new way to
immobilize and kill them
venom
over millions of years of evolution
snake venom has developed into a complex
cocktail of biological toxins that can
stop prey dead in their tracks
in most cases the amount intoxicity of
the venom delivered by a bite is far
beyond what is required to kill a single
animal
but why does it need to be so lethal
it's because venom serves many different
functions
it prevents prey from escaping it calms
them down stopping a return attack and
it also very importantly begins the
process of digestion
killing the prey is an added bonus not
just because it means that they can't
run away but also because it speeds up
the process of extracting the necessary
nutrients from the animal
but what's really astonishing about
snake venom is not only has it evolved
to be highly toxic to a snake's target
prey
venom has also found more than one way
of achieving this toxicity
the black mamba native to africa and the
coastal taipan native to australia are
both members of the alapid genus
they both have similar body sizes color
and venom toxicity and they both hunt
similar sized mammals like rats and mice
but the biological components of their
venom is very different
the black mamba's venom is mostly made
up from so-called kunitz type peptides
and three-finger neurotoxins but the
coastal taipan venom is made up of
mostly phospholipases
beta neurotoxins which have a completely
different mechanism of action to alpha
neurotoxins
we'll get on to how these different
toxins work later but this is just one
example of convergent evolution the
venom of these two species are designed
to do exactly the same thing but have a
very different composition
we see these large and small variations
in venom composition in similar snakes
across the world
let's take the three australasian
taipans as another example the central
range is taipan found in the mountainous
regions of western australia the coastal
taipan found along the east coast of
australia and the southern border of
papua new guinea and of course the
inland taipan found in the outback of
western queensland
each species survives on an entirely
mammalian diet and they all eat similar
sized animals but there are surprising
variations in the composition of their
venoms
the central ranges taipan like the black
mamba has venom made up from almost
entirely finger alpha neurotoxins
coastal taipan venom as we saw before is
mostly made up from phospholipase beta
neurotoxins and the inland taipan has a
deadly combination of both of these
types of neurotoxins
it's difficult to say exactly why the
inland taipan has evolved such a potent
venom
it might be because of the scarcity and
difficulty of catching its prey in the
open areas of the outback
but it could also be as a result of
random gene mutations that haven't been
selected against
either way there's no denying its
toxicity despite how powerful its venom
is the inland taipan will bite its prey
multiple times
recoiling after each strike to allow the
venom to surge through the body it
injects a mixture of toxic proteins into
the bloodstream and subcutaneous fat
which begin to act instantly first one
type of enzyme breaks down the proteins
in the blood and the blood vessels
loosening the connective tissue
weakening the walls of the capillaries
and triggering inflammation in the body
alongside this another type of enzyme
helps to increase the rate of absorption
and spread of the venom acting as a sort
of venom accelerant
so what actually kills the animal well
first there are the hemotoxins
inland taipan venom contains a number of
proteins which encourage clotting of the
blood
on small amounts of blood outside the
body this can cause it to turn into
jelly causing almost complete
coagulation but when acting on much
larger volumes of blood inside the body
the opposite occurs
thousands of small clots are formed very
rapidly using up almost all of the blood
clotting factors so instead of causing
coagulation of the blood it actually
prevents blood from clotting at the site
of the injury leading to potentially
lethal external bleeding
the next organs that are vulnerable are
the kidneys these might be directly
damaged by certain proteins in the
inland taipan venom or what's more
likely indirectly damaged by toxins that
affect the muscles
these myotoxins specifically target
muscle fibers
causing the release of damaged muscle
tissue into the bloodstream
the kidneys then kick into action trying
to remove the damaged tissue from the
blood but the myoglobin in the muscle
fibers is toxic to the kidneys blocking
the kidneys complex filtration system
and causing the organs to fail
on top of this the now severely damaged
and almost dead skeletal muscle pulls
large amounts of fluid from the blood
sending the body into shock but if the
animal by some miracle manages to
survive the bleeding and kidney failure
caused by this first set of toxic
proteins there is almost no chance it
will survive the effects of the second
set the neurotoxins the proteins that
are primarily responsible for the
venom's remarkable lethality
as we saw with black mamba and coastal
taipan venom these toxins are separated
into two categories alpha and beta
neurotoxins
the alpha neurotoxins in inland type and
venom are fast-acting deadly proteins
targeting acetylcholine receptors at the
junction between the muscles and the
nervous system
acetylcholine is a vital
neurotransmitter which allows the
nervous system to communicate with the
muscles controlling the contraction and
relaxation of muscle fibers
so when the venom's alpha neurotoxins
bind to these receptors they prevent
acetylcholine from binding stopping
communication between the brain and the
muscles leading to rapid muscular
paralysis
but despite how dangerous this sounds
this process is relatively easy to
reverse the binding of the toxin to the
receptor isn't very strong and if you're
bitten the paralysis caused by these
toxins can be overridden by
administering an antivenom as long as
it's injected within 30 minutes of the
bite
but things aren't quite as simple for
the other type of neurotoxin in inland
type and venom the beta neurotoxins
these are much slower acting but
considerably more lethal the primary
beta neurotoxin in inland taipan venom
is called paradoxin
and is part of a family of enzymatic
proteins that are found naturally within
cells
but in most cells their activity and
concentration are carefully controlled
due to the dramatic effect they can have
on the cellular machinery
paradoxin primarily acts on the
components of the cell membrane
specifically targeting the chemical bond
which joins the long chain fatty acid to
the glycerol molecule within a
phospholipid paradoxin breaks this bond
which by itself is enough to cause
significant damage to a cell potentially
rupturing the cell membrane but it's
actually the product of this reaction
that causes the biggest problems
when the phospholipid is broken it
releases a fatty acid chain
specifically a molecule called
arachidonic acid and it's this that
ultimately leads to permanent paralysis
and death
again like with the alpha neurotoxins
the site of action of paradoxin is the
neuromuscular junction the point of
connection between the nervous system
and the muscles
if paradoxin gets into the pre-synaptic
cell it'll start by breaking down
phospholipids to produce arachidonic
acid which then triggers a stream of
calcium ions to be released
cells are very sensitive to changes in
the amount of certain ions and this
large increase in calcium ion
concentration causes almost all of the
acetylcholine to be released from the
synapse
the acetylcholine travels across the
synapse and binds to its receptors
causing them to become desensitized and
turn off for a short period of time
by itself this wouldn't be enough to
cause paralysis
but now there's a critical problem with
the communication system
almost all of the acetylcholine has now
been used up
and even if the cell wanted to make more
it can't because the arachidonic acid
has also prevented reuptake of choline
the molecule required to make
acetylcholine
but this isn't the only problem caused
by paradoxine if it gets into the post
synapse it can also deactivate
acetylcholine receptors completely
again the same thing happens
phospholipids are broken down into
arachidonic acid which causes a massive
release of calcium ions
but this time the calcium ions activate
enzymes which turn off the acetylcholine
receptors
even causing them to be removed from the
cell membrane for a number of hours
the result of all of this is a complete
and irreversible shutdown of the
neuromuscular junction
the brain can't consciously or
unconsciously communicate with the
muscles and the body is totally
paralyzed the lungs can't inflate the
heart stops beating and the animal dies
of respiratory failure
there are many types of these beta
neurotoxins found in different snake
venoms
but paradoxin is the most potent of them
all
this by itself would make the venom
lethal but when combined with the many
other toxic proteins that affect
multiple systems and organs in the body
it makes inland taipan venom not only
the most dangerous snake venom in the
world but also one of the most dangerous
naturally occurring toxins ever to be
discovered
the natural world can be equally
devastating and astonishing
while it's fair if you don't want to
marvel at the wonder of snake venom up
close or even come within a thousand
feet of an inland taipan it's hard to
deny that they are incredible creatures
the best appreciation for the natural
world comes from understanding it and
understanding it comes from grasping
concepts across many subjects from
chemistry to biology to math to physics
and since it's been a while since my
high school and college science classes
i like to brush up on these concepts to
engage my brain and to help continuously
fulfill my curiosity for the natural
world and to do this i use brilliant
brilliant is an amazing tool for
learning stem interactively
it's less like a college textbook and
more like a series of quizzes puzzles
and funny animations that make the
learning engaging
often times the courses feel like a game
or riddle that leave me feeling
satisfied when i get the answer right
but if you get stuck on a particular
question brilliant doesn't penalize you
or impede your progress
instead they give you an in-depth
explanation to guide you to the right
one so you can learn from your mistakes
there are so many courses to dive into
from algorithm fundamentals to logic and
probability to mathematical fundamentals
which is the course i'm currently
working on this course covers the
foundational ideas of algebra number
theory and logic that come up in nearly
every topic across stem to get started
for free visit brilliant.org real
science or click on the link in the
description and the first 200 people
will get 20 percent off brilliant's
annual premium subscription
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about the spy pigeons of
the cold war or watch real engineering's
latest video about the way engineering
solved the mystery of the concord crash